Dark matter has been the go-to explanation
for many scientists as to why there seems
to be more gravitational influence in our
universe than the gravity measured by visible
matter.
But what if there’s no dark matter at all?
The idea of dark matter was first proposed
by Henri Poincaré in 1906.
Then in 1933, evidence of dark matter was
found by Fritz Zwicky while studying galaxy
clusters...
And then more evidence of dark matter was
found based on the calculations of rotational
velocities in galaxies made by Vera Rubin
in 1978.
Our universe is made up of less than 5% of
visible matter---like stars, planets, galaxies
you, me, everything we can see.
Everything else, is stuff we can’t see which
we call dark matter.
And scientists think 95% of the matter in
our universe is dark matter.
Right now, Dark Matter is used to explain
a few pesky things in astrophysics.
Liike…
Why hot galaxy clusters don’t blow themselves
apart.
Why stars don’t get flung out into space
because of galaxy rotation.
And also, the temperature fluctuations of
the CMB -- or cosmic microwave background
radiation.
That said, there are theories that are trying
to explain all this without assuming it’s
dark matter…These are: scale invariance
and emergent gravity.
The empty space scale invariance theory says
that properties of empty space should not
change based on scale.
An astrophysicist looked back at the early
equations of Einstein, and Newtonian Dynamics,
and modified an acceleration term in Newton's
law.
With this change, the law could explain a
new force.
This force can explain things that were explained
by dark matter… such as holding a galaxy
together that’s spinning at high rotational
velocities.
The only problem is, on Earth, this force
can be up to billion times smaller than the
force of gravity--making it difficult to measure.
It doesn’t explain gravitational lensing,
--which is the bending of light-- or the temperature
fluctuations of the CMB.
The craziest, but to me the most interesting,
is the holographic principle, which says that
our entire universe can be described on an
imaginary sphere that surrounds ordinary matter.
It lead to the theory of emergent gravity.
That is the idea that gravity arises (or emerges)
through the presence of matter.
This suggests this happens the same way temperature
arises from the movement microscopic particles
of matter.
So, if gravity is formed this way then it
can be used to explain gravitational phenomena
again!
Because something is keeping galaxies gravitationally
bound.
It’s possible that the force created in
the emergent gravity theory does this!
But it still doesn’t explain the CMB temperatures...
Scientists are still developing theories,
like these, so they can explain things like
the reason our universe hasn’t blown apart
because of invisible matter.
And they think it might be because of a gravitational
field that developed through the movement
of visible matter in our universe.
It’s all very complicated, and yet, epic.
At the moment, arguments for dark matter still
stand tall above many of these other theories,
but hey, maybe not forever.
Hey peeps, take a sec to subscribe for more
videos.
Plus, check out Trace’s video about a new
form of matter excitonium!
And one last fun fact: the holographic principle
says we’ve always looked at life as 3 dimensions,
but if we looked at it as 2 dimensions then
MAYBE the universe is just a holographic projection
of ourselves.
Thanks for watching!